[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya rosa pérez masdéu lista
conmigo en el estudio rosa muy buen día
feliz inicio de semana comenzamos hoy 4
de julio en eeuu una sociedad más
dividida por todo lo que hemos visto en
estos últimos días por supuesto la
erogación del aborto pues lo que ocurrió
con el acuerdo que hicieron demócratas y
republicanos en cuanto al control de
armas pero todavía según los demócratas
se queda corto cambio climático pandemia
y así lo ilustra la portada del new
york'
buenos días raúl exactamente no y es que
es un caso bien paradójico podríamos
decir eeuu donde hay una identidad
nacional tan fuerte pero tanta
discrepancia respecto a los valores que
tendría que representar este país y así
lo vemos con esta portada de new yorker
de chris ware que se titula como bien
decía casa dividida y vemos una casa en
la izquierda que representa pues la
vivienda de alguien más de izquierdas y
una casa a la derecha representando el
hogar de alguien más de derechas vemos
esos y algunos rasgos comunes por
ejemplo podríamos ver las dos personas
con la ahora en las pantallas de sus
celulares un rasgo muy transversal de
nuestros tiempos también los dos
sentados es así la persona más de
izquierdas en una hamaca la más de
derechas en un columpio esto digamos un
poco un elemento más paródico pero vamos
a fijarnos en otros detalles que sí que
denotan más las tendencias políticas
opuestas que ha querido representar esta
ilustración vemos por ejemplo en la casa
de izquierdas este cartel de black lives
meter y es que como bien decías el
racismo es una de las fracturas
profundas de la sociedad estadounidense
también vemos el cartel en esta misma
casa en esta casa creemos en la ciencia
recordemos que la gestión de la pandemia
las vacunas las leyes que obligaban al
uso de las mascarillas fueron elementos
muy polarizados y politizados de hecho
en eeuu fue uno de los países donde más
se politizó la gestión sanitaria de la
pandemia también vemos el cartel de
jardín polinizador un poco esta
conciencia ecologista la necesidad de
tomar acción contra el cambio climático
sin embargo vamos a la casa de la
derecha donde vemos que la persona que
yo vive
una gorra roja que bien podría ser la de
make américa great agent de los
seguidores de donald trump también vemos
el cartel si disfrutas la libertad
agradecerle a un veterano este elogio al
ejército y también la libertad este
concepto en el que caben tantas
definiciones pero que a lo ancho del
mundo se ha apropiado bastante la
derecha por otro lado también back the
blue una campaña para reforzar y apoyar
a la policía en relación a sus uniformes
azules y también vemos ese cartel de
sonría está siendo grabado está ante la
cámara este concepto de la seguridad
basado en la vigilancia privada en el
que cabe también un poco pues la postura
al respecto de las armas y precisamente
reducen esta revista encontramos una
opinión de janine sixers en que dice los
conservadores de la corte suprema han
afirmado su poder pero qué pasa si sus
movimientos drásticos que destruyen
ciertos derechos constitucionales e
inflan otros están destinados a
colisionar bien pues lo que defiende
este artículo con una ilustración de iau
facenda que también hemos querido
señalar porque también es muy
vemos como la sombra de la corte
suprema- dibuja una cruz cristiana en
una representación de cómo estas
decisiones quizás tienen más que ver con
una cierta ideología fundamentalista
cristiana bien este artículo para
resumir dice que donald trump además de
un intento de golpe de estado también
hay que agradecerle que 2022 se
convirtiera en un punto de inflexión de
la revolución conservadora en la corte
suprema- y repasa brevemente las
decisiones de esta corte en una semana a
finales de junio dice los jueces
conservadores afirmaron su poder
consolidando y consolidado al expandir
los derechos de porte de armas de moler
el derecho al aborto a nivel federal
recordemos abrir un agujero en el muro
que separa iglesia y estado y limitar la
posibilidad de combatir el cambio
climático dice sea cual sea el futuro de
trump si finalmente logra presentarse de
nuevo a las elecciones presidenciales
presidenciales o si se abre una
investigación judicial contra él dice
sea como sea nos quedamos con su corte y
el daño que causará para las próximas
generaciones igual todo apunta a que en
2004 trump pues se lanzaría
pues nuevamente buscar la presidencia de
eeuu como dice usted si no le impide
algún fallo actual o alguna
investigación en su corte ahora con el
washington post que señala la
legitimidad de la corte suprema que está
cada vez más en entredicho
efectivamente en un artículo que firman
a tres periodistas reportaje a dos nos
hemos querido fijar en las cifras que da
este texto dice que tras el fallo del 24
de junio está revocación de la sentencia
de roe versus wade que protegía el
derecho al aborto
a nivel federal digamos la aprobación de
la corte suprema- cayó 16 puntos el año
pasado esta aprobación era del 60% y
tras la filtración de hecho de estas
deliberaciones por parte de la corte
suprema que recordemos filtro político
antes de que fuera oficial la valoración
la popularidad la aprobación de este
órgano judicial cayó hasta el 44 por
ciento siendo los republicanos mucho más
favorables a este órgano lo aprueban en
un 71 por ciento mientras los demócratas
lo aprueban en un 28 por ciento
ahora con las protestas contra la
decisión de revocar el fallo histórico
roe versus wade en eeuu y se ha
popularizado un dibujo de la dietista
francesa coco que publicó en libération
efectivamente como señalamos esta viñeta
cuando salió en su momento tras esta
filtración de político a la que nos
referíamos y luego éste me dio
liberación la usó en su portada cuando
cayó finalmente esta revocación el 24 de
junio la hermosa he querido volver a
señalar porque como decías se ha
popularizado en las protestas contra
esta decisión de la corte suprema porque
como vamos a ver es una viñeta a la que
no hacen falta añadir palabras y si te
parece veamos muy rápidamente la
explicación de la autora de esta viñeta
a por qué dibujo lo que finalmente
dibujo
más que donde podemos apreciar en el
dibujo que el rojo de la bandera se
convierte en la sangre de las mujeres en
su sufrimiento se derrama y dibuja la
bandera de eeuu
y es con su rastro de sangre que ellas
muestran y simbolizan en qué país va a
convertirse a eeuu para ellas es decir
dolor y sufrimiento si
bien esta sustitución de las estrellas
de la bandera por ahora los ganchos no
que se usan claro un símbolo del aborto
clandestino raúl fuerte de viñeta rosa
gracias por toda la información mañana
más revista de prensa pasamos a saludar
a nuestro primer invitado el día